and he said oh no sir I must say wrong
I must disagree
she's preoccupied
so
what's up Ralph ism
Cartier lifestyle
[Music]
that's what she said
yeah over you she said that she said
yeah
she said that that's what he said she
said that like that's what she said is
to say
[Music]
[Music]
stop
what's up guys hello Chad how are you
I'm not gonna hit the spot one second
[Laughter]
laughs
okay
and we're back
okay guys
here we go
today we work on the new push push trees
collection
all right
always for Life stuff is coming up let
me give you guys a quick update
quick update
um
wow I just I just spaced how hard some
of those like you just forgot what
you're about okay what it was I was
listening to the dog that I can hear
through the floor
of this apartment building
and thinking I can't wait to move out
that dog is so is so loud
yeah dog
um so this was going on I fired my
printers or pushed trees after nine
years
they actually tried to scam me I didn't
tell you the ones from Frisco do the
ones I've been dealing with my whole
career yeah
um they try to play me
and I caught them
and that's why I was like you know what
I've been kind of a dick lately not a
dick but I've been like no do things
right like I usually like it's okay bro
it's okay and now it's like hey um I'm
sorry but you're fired so I've been I've
been I don't know I get in these modes
like every couple months
I get irritated enough to where I go you
know what
no I paid you you have to do what you're
doing yeah anyway they tried to scam me
on some [ __ ] really crazy he almost
wanted me to sign an NDA
um but I didn't
so that
and the poop the new push trees
backpacks were supposed to be here two
months ago
I bought a thousand backpacks
and uh
all of them were wrong
every single one of them
that dog's loud so we had to redo them
and that's what's going on right now
and all the new orders of shirts all
peeled and that's why I found out what
was going on my printers and then I
fired them
so I have like a my first house that I
grew up in worth of money tied up that I
don't have any product for
it's been six five months I've been
waiting so I'm sorry
um yeah
that's what's going on with those trees
another thing I guess I could talk about
this a little bit Razzie ix0 you say
will the dopa shop ever be International
we are working on the dopest uh Europe
right now
so we're going to be set up in Europe
soon
all right we're also going to be set up
in Canada soon
and hopefully if it all goes well
Australia
because it's a ITC is legal everywhere
but we can't ship there it's illegal to
ship so if we set up our hubs there
so we're working on that right now so
there might be some jobs opening up oh
over there in London
but that means I get to go
yeah that's the whole point like oh go
to England
so that's what we're doing right now
guys we're trying to work on all that oh
new editor I have a new editor guys
well no no I got an extra editor because
Marty does not have the mental bandwidth
to handle everything we're doing he's
about to because the podcast is about to
free up
but I feel like editing is a little like
under Marty's time right now like he
needs to be doing bigger and better
things than editing my videos
all the time yeah you can still edit but
I think his time's worth more than that
at this point so we're trying to like
find new people to help
came into the email video Blah
the 11. oh my God what's it
oh god well the new editor hit me up
four days ago I didn't I missed it
that sucks
sorry I'm getting a call
um but yeah the Dover shop we have this
new subscription boxes out lemon
cherries out we have a bunch of stuff
going on right now I'm really stoked
about it
and uh yeah
this this week Texas is for uh Dallas
Texas is Friday
and Houston is Sunday
he drank the juice
[Laughter]
John from dopa shop is sick
so we bought him a bunch of Health
juices
it's bad just drink it and Chase it with
water
Chase it with a little bit of water
it's disgusting John
I know but you'll go to sleep John's
most unhealthy guy ever
that's why he called me and then he
called Rosie immediately to show him how
nasty it is
sorry guys there's a bunch of stuff
going on right now but yeah today is the
day Ralph and I are doing the push trees
collection so
new one coming out besides the homies
for life besides the backpacks and also
we're working on our first plushies so
Plushies are coming out
um and stuff Ted Talk was the six we
already filmed it
yeah hypnotics exactly there's so much
stuff happening at all times my bad
would you recommend the original Focus
to Carter II no no number two
um
hit the unscrewable bong if I get this
job oh talk about the dopest uh I mean
dope as usual box dope as usual
podcast.com
so yeah
Chris uh the Chris udala episode drops
next Monday today is Charlie rocket
today's episode guys if you have any
friends that are entrepreneurs have
small businesses content creators
or anybody just I would say in the
entrepreneurial world this is the
episode to watch
when Charlie left the pot the warehouse
and he left me and Marty went back in
the room and we just talked about the
episode for about 15 minutes
this dude
the what the motivation and the point of
the dove as usual podcast that me and
Marty always try to get across this guy
Charlie articulated it in a way where I
could I wish I could say that yeah I
wish I could say what he said obviously
he's a public speaker and he's been
speaking like that for a long time so it
comes more natural to him I'm still
working on it we do the podcast and uh
what was I gonna say we do the podcast
and um
I don't have like a boss I don't have to
do stuff so you know I speak how I speak
and definitely this bowl is seasoned in
public speaking because the [ __ ] he
broke down this episode's guys he
explained negativity and quantum physics
using our bongs
I just need you to hear that he used
four of our bombs to explain a slide of
quantum physics that made so much sense
to me
it's a good episode I'm very excited
uh probably I don't want to I mean I I
will say I think it is the
best conversation we've ever had
I wouldn't say the best episode because
there's been some episodes that are like
conversations wild but it's just a fun
hilarious goofy you know but this one
was the best conversation for sure the
best that dog is loud
it's the best conversation we've ever
had on the show me and Marty were
tripping after he left like dude that
was
put it this way it was such a good
conversation I forgot to light my joints
I had joints rolled completely forgot to
light them guys because I got so lost in
conversation
it was fine after I smoked them after
but still
it was great
um
dude
a dog sucks
evoking was
when did the Ted Talk video drop uh it's
supposed to be in February it takes a
month
for them to do all their stuff car
update I have no update
at all we wish we did but oh we're
moving
we're moving we found our spot we put
the application today we're moving all
right
when I post your thing on Instagram I
was like whoa you're showing a lot of
our house
but then I was like oh that's not even
the house
a little bit of it yeah I don't care now
that's why we're moving oh who doesn't
care anymore yeah I'll start showing the
view here because if you yeah yeah our
the penthouse whatever it keeps messing
up guys yeah just no no thanks and I
won't say yet
but there look it on the penthouse floor
we're the only people for three months
and then one other person moved in and I
don't like this dude he's weird
he gave me a terrible Vibe and he only
looked straight down at his phone and
walks onto the elevator while I'm trying
to walk off you know I'm on the elevator
I'm trying to walk off like normal
manners and how it works and the fool
just will just
Dart right in looking straight down at
this phone doesn't matter who's in front
of him it could be a kid
but now I just walk straight toward him
because I'm bigger and I just look at
him as I walk by him anyway I just found
out whose fool is I won't say who it is
I found out who this guy is I'm like he
must be a streamer there's no way he can
afford this place there's no way that
kid could afford this place and he's not
a streamer he doesn't do anything unless
his parents are rich and I'm not saying
in a bougie way I'm saying like how do
you live here
you only stare at your phone this close
and walk
guys crazy not crazy and I was like hey
man he might be slow remember I told you
I'm like you know I don't want to get
mad
okay
well not signed yet so we're fine gotcha
anyway yeah I'm leaving the contract I'm
leaving the place I forgot that's where
the NDA was
the apartment's so sick
who love it I'm moving because the
location I want to be further
this new topic yeah new topic anyway
when we leave I'll tell you about who it
is I found out who this guy is and I'm
like of course makes perfect sense
yeah streamers
anyway
um Marty what up I didn't sign it yet so
we're okay but I'll stop anyway yeah I
guess there was an NDA for my apartment
I forgot hey every time I talked about
it it's been prior so we're okay
damn I completely forgot all right one
minute new episode dropping in guys
thank you so much appreciate it um
yeah I'm excited this episode's good uh
there's no weed in it so that's pretty
wild guys check us out new video popping
out right now go drop a like go hop in
have a best day
increase your dollar podcast next week